so tonight we're really lucky to have
Stephen watts back Stephen Watts has
been called by another good biographer
Robert Westbrook a biographer of John
doing a plutarch of modern America
because of his books on Walt Disney his
book on Q Hefner which he talked about
urine in the library
and Henry Ford and now Dale Carnegie
he's a professor of history at the
University of Missouri former chair of
the of the history department at the
University and and Dale Carnegie I have
a lecture that I give periodically
people take about a year and a half for
people to forget that I've given it
before and then I give it in in which in
which is the title of it is Missouri the
center of the literary universe and you
know we talk about TS Eliot and Mark
Twain talk about things that some people
don't know that the best-selling
cookbook of all times course written in
st. Louis by Herman Rombauer I always
like to refer to the first sentence of
the first edition as the greatest
sentence in American literature stand
facing the stove
but also as part of this lecture I
always tell people that that one of the
greatest self-help book ever written was
written by a missourian who always
identified himself as as you read
Stephen wants his excellent biography
you'll find out always identify himself
as a Missouri ms Dale Carnegie who was
born in small town in Northwest Missouri
and is buried in a increasingly not so
small town of Belton just to the south
of us a part of our suburbs Dale
Carnegie was a true a true missourian
and when you think about it Walt Disney
a true a true Missourian and and Jesse
James a true Missourian you know they
were all in one way or another into self
fulfillment and and and Steven Steven
wants rights this wonderful genealogy
really starts with Benjamin Franklin and
and moves through the the various 19th
century purveyors of self development
who are so important in in American
culture and gums up to Dale Carnegie who
is the apotheosis of self development
and ends his book with as I hope he'll
talk about in his in his talk tonight
with Oprah Winfrey and you think about
the the the direction that the destiny
of self development goes from from from
self control with with Benjamin Franklin
to self-esteem with with Oprah Winfrey
with this deep deep stop with Dale
Carnegie this is a powerful book because
it really is not just a biography of
Dale Carnegie it's a biography of the
emotional development of the United
States and and it's not all necessarily
good but as Steven Watts will will tell
you it's all really nice
ladies and gentlemen Stephen watts
[Applause]
well I just told Crosby he's a hard hard
act to follow here Dale Carnegie would
be proud I think you will have to excuse
me I've had a terrible cold so I may
begin a sort of croaking like a frog
here so just pretend it's all quite
natural
ever since Rob Westbrook wrote that
thing from my book about Plutarch I'd be
giving my book promotion talks dressed
in a toga but now I decided my legs
weren't good enough so I got the suit
instead tonight well they do want to
talk about my book about Dale Carnegie
this evening now who is I think very
influential cultural figure in this
country for reasons that I hope to lay
out a little bit of my talk and if
you're kind enough to get the book I
would be happy to sign it for you
afterwards the notion of success I think
lay at the heart of the American dream
when in fact the idea of the individual
moving head in the race of life pulling
yourself up by your own bootstraps as
the old familiar saying has it I think
it's embedded in our national DNA all of
us have heard I think some version of go
makes something of yourself go make
something out of yourself usually from
anxious parents during our adolescence
when we prepare to go off to college and
actually I think from the founding days
of the Republic boosters and moralists
politicians and shysters although avers
risk redundancy on those last year I
think they've been instructing people on
the best way to improve their social
status and increase their material
possessions which are the two big parts
of course of the success formula in the
18th century Benjamin Franklin actually
I have some slides that this works there
we go
Benjamin Franklin I think was the first
great success writer in American history
and for Richard's Almanack
the early part of the 18th century and
then of course in his autobiography that
was eventually published later in the
1700s Franklin stressed the work ethic
and thrift in particular as the ways to
success all the things I'm sure most of
you have heard early to bed early to
rise makes a man healthy wealthy and
wise penny saved is a penny earned on
and on in that vein well a few decades
later in the 19th century Horatio Alger
I think of course became the great
avatar of success in the 19th century
the great formulator of success in a
series of novels that in all honesty
were literary train wrecks but
culturally I think their gems are really
interesting cultural documents indeed
many best-selling books have marked the
match boy strive to succeed all of them
with very similar titles essentially
Alger told the same story over and over
and over again he just changed the
characters a little bit story was a
virtuous young man often an orphan who
came from the countryside to the big
city and he climbed to success he rose
to distinction through upstanding
character self-denial and unstinting
labor and for Victorian individuals up
until about the end of the 19th century
Alger's directives were a kind of
cultural gospel well what about the
modern era who has been the great avatar
of success writing in the American
Century as it's often term well it
happens to be a missourian from a rural
backwater in the northwestern part of
the state I was born up near Maryville
who rose to become I think the greatest
purveyor of success principles in modern
life and whose efforts inspired a horde
of disciples who have followed in his
wake and that is of course Dale Carnegie
the subject of my talk and
my biography in one sense this book
which is still one of the best-selling
books in American history
some people rank it among the top three
or four best-selling non-fiction books
still in our in our collective lives in
a certain sense Carnegie in this book I
think operated in the tradition of
Franklin and Alger but as we're going to
see here in a little bit he also recast
I think their instructions to reflect
many of the issues and conditions that
were work in modern life how to win
friends and influence people in fact I
argue is a kind of brilliant reflection
of deeper values that Americans have
come to embrace in the 20th century but
Carnegie I was shocked to discover a few
years ago has never had a full scale
biography and so explaining his work is
sort of the burden of my book self-help
Messiah which came out last October I
would note that this book is absolutely
essential reading for everyone who does
not want to be an abject miserable
failure in modern America and get ahead
it also along those lines I think makes
a wonderful inspirational gift for
graduations bar mitzvahs wedding showers
Christmas all national holidays of major
world religions etc etc that paragraph
was written by my publisher actually so
well at any rate Carnegie himself I
think offers a fascinating story of rags
to riches in his own life he was born
tie as I noted before up near Marysville
Missouri into a youth of sort of
grinding poverty and he spent a youth I
think that was equally influenced on one
hand by his father's repeated failures
as a farmer in in the late 19th century
and on the other hand by his
others intense Protestantism intense
Protestant piety Dale by the way is a
little guy in front that is his older
brother behind him Clifton young Dale
Carnegie was very bright he was very
intellectually curious and he found the
kind of escape from his boyhood of
youthful poverty by developing a talent
for public speaking his mother was
something of a lay preacher in that part
of the state in this period and Dale
goes off to college at Lawrenceburg at
State Teachers College at Lawrenceburg
and he becomes a kind of big man on
campus as a public speaker as an orator
back in those days he was quite slight
and he had big years he was very sort of
self-conscious about his ears
and he discovered the only way he could
compete with the football players was to
be an orator in the late 19th century
and that's sort of where he made his
mark but then things got very
interesting he's very ambitious it was
very tired of the Midwest and he was so
sort of grating against the religious
heritage of his family in particular of
his mother and he wanted to make it he
wanted to get ahead and what he did was
he headed off to New York to make good
the old saying of course was go west
young man well Carnegie of course went
east young man to make his fortune but
success did not come immediately with
Dale Carnegie he went through as a
matter of fact a kind of lengthy
roustabout period I guess I would call
it where he struggled through a series
of jobs he was a meat salesman an actor
a car salesman a magazine journalist a
failed novelist and he even entered into
a kind of partnership I found this quite
interesting with Lowell Thomas the
famous writer and journalist in the
Lawrence of Arabia shows that Laurel
Thomas put together after World War one
carnaby Carnegie became his right-hand
man and was very involved putting
on these shows both in England and in
the United States after all of this
comes back to New York and he finally
settles into a kind of solid career as a
as an instructor of public speaking and
he began his efforts at the YMCA in
Brooklyn part-time teaching a small
number of students in the late nineteen
teens on through the teens and on
through the 1920s and he steadily
refines his techniques and refined his
course and it began to establish a
national reputation by about 1930 or so
his public speaking course what will
later become the famous carnegie course
is so popular that thousands and
thousands of people are attending it all
up and down the East Coast and in
addition it's attracting some of the
biggest companies in the United States
who are beginning to send their people
there to be trained in public speaking
by Dale Carnegie who focused on things
like building confidence and social
skills and personal image as his career
begins to take off he begins to appear
in newspapers all over the country
begins something of a minor celebrity in
American life and eventually he lands
his first big gig on NBC radio now where
he's given a show which runs for a
couple of years out of New York he also
writes a very I guess I would call it an
inspirational biography of Abraham
Lincoln that sells very fairly well and
then he wrote a very chatty kind of book
that encapsulated a lot of his radio
pieces that was called little-known
facts about well-known people Carnegie
is doing pretty well in this period up
into the early 30s it was in the mid 30s
however that Carnegie in a way gets his
big break in the heart of the Great
Depression the period when he really
becomes a kind of cultural icon for the
first time a man named Leon
who was in acquisitions editor at Simon
& Schuster and Shemp gun would go on to
a long and very influential career as
the head of Simon Shuster after this he
takes Carnegie's course he loves it and
he decides that Carnegie's ideas need a
kind of national audience a much broader
audience and he convinces Carnegie to
write a book sort of put his lectures
together Carnegie is reluctant he had
submitted some book manuscripts to Simon
& Schuster they turned them down and he
was kind of disgruntled about that so a
Shem Ken had to kind of talk him into it
but eventually Carnegie sort of bends to
the task and in December of 1936 he
publishes a book called how to win
friends and influence people now when
this book came out and as it was being
put together I think both Carnegie and
the press had fairly modest hopes for
its sales they hoped that it would sell
a reasonable amount of copies and
everyone make a little bit of money and
go home happy
but the results were astonishing and
they quickly just sort of overwhelmed
the expectations of everyone involved
copies began to fly off the shelves
everywhere in the United States and four
months after its release a stunned
Leon simpkin wrote this letter to
Carnegie in which he said and I quote I
found this in the Carnegie archives if
one year ago a friend of mine were to
have told me that today I was going to
send to an author the 250,000 copy of
his book for months I would have either
referred him to the nearest psychiatrist
or to Robert Ripley for a believe it or
not cartoon in coat how to win friends
would go on to sell about a million
copies in the first year year and a half
and eventually by the time the dust has
settled it's been estimated that that
book has so somewhere in the vicinity of
30 million copies in the United States
around the globe and it has joined I
think a select group
of books in American history that have
combined enormous popularity with the
kind of genuine cultural influence joins
books like I guess the Bible Uncle Tom's
Cabin Gone with wind the kinsey reports
dr. Spock's baby and child care and last
but not least Fifty Shades of Grey
no none of you I'm sure know know
anything about that last one so well the
big question I think though is why did
Carnegie's book proved to be so enormous
ly popular in the 1930s what happened in
the culture that made it so responsive
to what Carnegie had to say well in the
broadest sense what I argue in this book
is that Carnegie presented a formula for
success and how to win friends and
influence people that was particularly
attuned to some key qualities in modern
American life in the 20th century it was
aimed I think very shrewdly at the
legions of new white collar workers in
modern America people in the middle
class who were working in the hundreds
of big companies and complex
bureaucracies that had emerged after the
beginning of the 20th century in
business in government in education in
media in entertainment as well over over
the early decades of the 1900s
there was in America an army I think a
very large army of clerks and office
workers and middle managers salesmen
advertisers marketers teachers salaried
employees of all kinds and these are
people who wanted to succeed but they
were people for whom the old advice of
Benjamin Franklin and Horatio Alger had
a very limited appeal
and very sort of limited use in their
everyday lives
the Franklin announced your advice about
hard work firm moral character
credential habits of saving and thrift
all of this I think seemed irrelevant in
many ways in this new society where in
people's daily lives in Bureau
bureaucratic settings they were involved
in interactions on a daily basis with
dozens and maybe even hundreds of people
over and over again the old standard I
think of Hardy individualism just did
not do much for them in in this new
environment or Carnegie's book how to
win friends I think
addressed the situation directly and it
presented an irresistible message that
people responded to very
enthusiastically and that message was
quite simply that one could find success
in the modern world by developing
attractive personal traits by developing
and displaying self-confidence by
developing skills in human relations and
most simply as Carnegie would put it by
getting people to like you getting
people to like you that was the game in
a lot of ways Carnegie insisted and as
some of you may know if you've read this
book he insists on it over and over
again that getting ahead in life
securing a better job making more money
enjoying the esteem of your co-workers
and so on that all of this was mainly a
matter now in the twentieth century of
enhancing your personal attractiveness
and with perky enthusiasm and Carnegie
was nothing if not perky I might add he
promised that his advice book would help
any individual and these are his words
here to get out of a mental rut to think
new thoughts acquired new visions
acquired new ambitions win people to
your way of thinking
increase your influence your prestige
your ability to get things done when new
clients new customers handle complaints
avoid arguments keep your human contact
smooth and pleasant input so what was
the significance of this new success
creed that Carnegie shapes in this book
well first of all what I would suggest
you and I think this is very very
important
what Carnegie's message embodied was a
very significant shift in American
culture from character to personality as
I often tell my students in my various
courses in the Victorian age in the
1800s the standard was one of stern
morality self-control the character
ethic as the Victorians liked to call it
and that's what regulated individual
contact but what you have in the 20th
century I think increasingly is this
vast socio-economic change that really
remade American society the American
economy and American culture in
significant fashion what you have is a
new kind of America that takes shape
that is increasingly devoted to consumer
abundance to bureaucratic definitions of
work to leisure and entertainment as key
activities in our lives and in this
world the old ideal of Victorian
self-denial
seemed antiquated completely out of
touch so what you see here I think and I
think you see it quite clearly in
Carnegie's own life is that the old high
bound strictures of character begin to
recede into the background and instead
new sparkling images of personality
again to take its place and it becomes
central to a new code of individualism
what you have is a new notion at work
here of the shaping of a healthy
magnetic charismatic personal image
rather than that
internalized character ethic of old
fogies and this new charismatic
personality is crucial to your success
in the new world of self-fulfillment and
bureaucracy and a consumer economy well
then how to win friends and influence
people I think Carnegie captured all of
this beautifully and in in the book he
he lays out these new principles of
personality in what would become his
trademark breathless anecdotal style and
he makes this book I think really the
guidebook for success in modern America
in modern American culture in words I
I'm pretty convinced that would have
horrified a Victorian audience only 20
30 40 years before he declares in this
book and I quote one can no longer put
much faith in the old adage that hard
work alone is the magic key that will
unlock the door to our desires instead
he insists that it's the ability to
handle people with your personality I
mean he repeats this over and over again
in the book that is the key to
achievement to status to material
prosperity in modern society success in
America Carnegie tells his readers over
and over again depends on getting along
with other people working smoothly with
others in a kind of bureaucratic milieu
and subtly maneuvering to assume
leadership in groups of people and
e-tailers this advice in the book to
those kinds of principles and these are
all his principles and his phrases and
I'm just going to recite a few of them I
think you'll see exactly what I mean
make the other person feel important
don't criticize others establish a
positive atmosphere and avoid arguments
be Hardy and approbation and lavish in
praise let the other fella feel that had
the idea is his
and finally the icing on the cake make
people like you and quote well to this
end he encourages success seekers I
think in the book to engage in
self-examination this is know what habit
of course in American culture the
Victorians did this
the Puritans I think even before them
you always need to look inward to make
sure you're sort of on the straight and
narrow path but what's different with
Carnegie's injunctions along these lines
is they change shape very dramatically
the Puritans the Victorians said look
into yourself to examine your character
flaws to examine your spiritual failings
your your failings in morality as a
human being
Carnegie has a very different idea he
tells readers to keep a file like the
one he did and it's right there in the
Carnegie archives still and it's called
and I quote damned fool things I have
done and quote and what's fascinating
about it is all these injunctions to
self examination there's nary a word
about spiritual failings or moral
falling back anything of the kind
instead the whole focus is on social
errors and the damn fool things that I
have done in Carnegie's rendering is of
this is to forget people's names to
blurt out negative comments to talk too
much around other people to fail to make
other people feel comfortable to argue
with people instead of tactfully
suggesting new ways of thinking about
things to overlook other people's
viewpoints and not listen to them and to
make sweeping statements that other
people found irritable those were all
damnable things that I have done and
Carnegie urged people to sort of light
those out of one's personality pardon me
here's where the frog part comes in I
think uh with Carnegie in other words
what I would suggest excuse me what I
would suggest is that you can see
American values shifting from the old
notion of inner moral character to
shaping one's image and the impressions
that you make upon other people in a
kind of modern setting so from character
and personality I think that's one big
source of its significance secondly and
I think in addition to that shift what
you all see what we also see and how to
win friends and influence people is a
newfound emphasis historically on
psychology as a key dynamic in modern
American life as a number of critics and
historians have observed I think Oh in
over the last 30 or 40 years probably
and probably most famously Phillip
wreath in a brilliant book called the
triumph of the therapeutic they
suggested that in the modern world but a
kind of slow erosion of connections
among people community ties religious
obligations and so on what's been
produced in the modern West particularly
in America is this ideal type of
psychological man this modern character
type is preoccupied with self-awareness
preoccupied with self esteem is engaged
in a kind of unceasing quest for
fulfillment in one way or another for
emotional well-being psychological man
in short I think has jettisoned morality
for therapy as a kind of way to be in
the world and I think it's quite clear
that this new therapeutic sensibility
began spread spreading in American
culture by the middle decades of the
20th century and it has become I think
an enormous influence in our modern
values as it has spread into our
thinking about education child rearing
family life religion I think even
political ideology as well
well Carnegie I think was at the
absolute heart of this process and kind
of psychologizing of modern American
culture
he liked to present himself as an expert
in his phrase practical psychology and
he emerged I think is really the first
great popularizer of this newfound
stress on mental health and self-esteem
the Carnegie course that he presented
all the way up to his death in the
mid-1950s tried to eradicate what
Carnegie called the inferiority complex
that people would bring into his courses
he advertised the course for its
reliance on the significant discoveries
of modern psychology and in how to win
friends and influence people you may
know if you read that book he instructed
readers that when you're dealing with
people and this is his phrase we are not
dealing with creatures of logic we are
dealing with creatures of emotion end
quote and throughout that book littered
in each and every chapter are the
psychological ideas sort of popularized
William James Alfred Adler Sigmund Freud
and a whole host of lesser figures and
using them Carnegie urges his readers
over and over again to continuously
gauge the psychological needs of people
they're involved with co-workers
families associates and so on in society
clients and to try to meet those needs
with with psychological sensitivity he
advocated for example positive thinking
the art of appreciation which he
describes the easiest of all
psychological techniques to help people
feel comfortable to win friends and
influence people and titled his famous
book how to win friends would make he
argues in that book and I quote here
again the principles of psychology easy
for you to apply in your
context and it would create among
readers a new way of life he says that
will pave the way to success
so from this collection of cultural
ingredients success ideology these
notions of charismatic personality
positive thinking human relations
therapeutic well-being Carnegie created
I think what was his ultimate legacy in
American culture and that is the
establishment of a robust self-help
movement that has shaped modern American
culture in fundamental ways indeed in
the wake of his stunning success I think
a host of dazzling popular self-help
gurus have spread out over the American
landscape norman vincent peale tony
robbins robert schuller marianne
williamson M Scott Peck Deepak Chopra
Stephen Covey the one mentioned earlier
in the introduction Oprah Winfrey
countless others those are just sort of
the all-star team I think they have
fanned out I think into our daily lives
presenting these messages of personal
improvement human relations therapeutic
adjustment as techniques for getting
head and prospering and achieving self
fulfillment in our modern life but
Carnegie's basic notion I think that was
embodied in how to win friends and
influence people that the individual who
learns Carnegie's words the fine art of
getting along with people in everyday
business and social contact will enjoy
more profit more leisure and what is
infinitely more important more happiness
in business and in home life this book I
think became the text of this modern
success creed I think Dale Carnegie is
sort of the godfather of self-help in
modern American life
Carnegie went on to a rich and full life
after
publication of this book in the 1930s he
flourished as a beloved teacher who in
the Carnegie course all the way up
through the 40s and 50s still spent
really the great majority of his time
with the carnegie course around the
country franchised all over the United
States and eventually around the globe
and it still graduates hundreds of
people every year from the course which
is still flourishing he became a
best-selling author once again in 1948
with a book called how to stop worrying
and start living which was a kind of
guide book for stressed-out suburbanite
after world war ii who had become
prosperous but they still weren't happy
and Carnegie's sort of wrote this book
as a way to ease them toward happiness i
might also note that after finally
marrying at a fairly advanced age he
became a father for the first time at
the fairly advanced age of 63 something
I can identify with I didn't quite make
that mark but I did my part here with
the pictured here with the younger woman
he married and his daughter Donna who
was there who was a born in the early
50s so he does become a father in this
period at least officially I also feel
obligated to note that actually one of
the most interesting things about this
book I stumbled across some rather how
to describe this curious letters that
were in the Carnegie archives and
neither Carnac family ignored the
Carnegie people knew anything about them
and they were from a woman and I played
Sherlock Holmes a little bit and I ended
up discovering this secret life the Dale
Carnegie had that he had a long loving
relationship with a married woman and
a child resulted from this that Carnegie
believed was his and with absolutely no
one knowing about it even his family up
to about one year ago he supported this
girl financially and emotionally as well
he became good friends not only with his
mistress but with his mistress's husband
who was a blind man who had studied to
be a rabbi one never knows what you're
going to run across in research but
actually it's a fascinating story about
sort of a larger context I suppose of
winning friends and influencing people
but if you want to know what that's all
about you'll have to have to buy the
book so to bring all of this to a close
I think in an overarching sense what I
would like to leave you with is the idea
I guess that Carnegie Dale Carnegie's
impact as a historical figure what was
really profound because I think he is
the greatest popular spokesman for
modern ideas about success in the
culture that we still inhabit today and
I think whatever you make of the modern
therapeutic culture of personality and
self-esteem you have to acknowledge the
crucial efforts of an ambitious farm boy
from Missouri in shaping its powerful
role long ago of course it was Thomas
Jefferson who coined the most American
of phrases the pursuit of happiness but
it was Dale Carnegie I would suggest who
defined the modern meaning of that
phrase
the end
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]
reference to professor Watson please
come up to the microphone and also
remind you that the book is for self
more attention Barnes & Noble outside
wait the start here oh thank you
thanks for your talk just a quick
question in view of the fact that Dale
Carnegie had such an impact on multiple
generations and can also considering
that Rush Limbaugh is in the Missouri
Hall of Fame I couldn't help but wonder
if indeed Dale Carnegie's in the
Missouri Hall of Fame
thank you oh I thought you could ask
something different'
I believe he is yes as a matter of fact
and I also just found out that the
Warrensburg folks called me a few weeks
ago and I think they're creating a Hall
of Fame at that Central Missouri
University I believe it's called now and
they're going to have a little ceremony
in the fall for Carnegie I think they've
commissioned a bus to him and so on so
yes he's getting recognition here today
yes thank you
so you mentioned his damn-fool things
I've done but they were kind of you know
nonspecific did he mention like who they
happened with or what was the context of
some of those yeah it's really actually
it was great reading because his private
writing was much like his public writing
it was very perky and interesting and he
sort of lashing himself you know he said
well I had a meeting with you know Joe
Schmoe and some other people and you
know when he cussed a little bit you
know he said you know damned if I didn't
run my mouth off the whole time and they
couldn't get a word in edgewise and then
I sat back and thought I didn't hear
anything they say Oh what was I
all kinds of examples a sort of social
encounter specific ones where you had
the interesting specter of the man who
wrote the book trying to remember to
apply his own principles to himself
fanned out he sometimes he met them
sometimes he fell short but very
specific yes I was wondering how much
you felt these principles apply in 2014
in that the things that come to my mind
in terms of influencing people I think
we'd probably want to Koch brothers
maybe to write that book and the
internet for example as a source of
information and the source of influence
seems to overshadow a great deal an
individual personality and their
agreeableness or their ability to get
along that's a very good question I
think and I think my answer to it would
be kind of complex I think as far as the
internet goes that I am sensing that the
Internet is changing our life and our
culture in ways that we're only dimly
beginning to appreciate and the honest
answer to that is I don't know because
the students that I teach these days I
often talk to my wife every year they
seem just a little bit more alien to me
because
coming out of this kind of social media
interconnected culture where there is a
very different wavelength from those of
us in a slightly earlier period so in
that sense I'm not sure but maybe in a
broader sense
I still think his principles are very
applicable as far as interacting with
other people because I still think it's
a fact that economically and socially
and culturally in all kinds of ways it's
big bureaucratic institutions that still
structure a good deal of what we do and
I think the work life that many of us
still have is still in that setting and
so I think those principles still work
the example that leaps to mind is a
personal one and that is mentioned in
the introduction I was the chairman of
the history department for about five
years I used to have a full head of hair
before that and yeah that will drive you
to distraction or drink one or the other
but I found myself when I was the chair
of the this organization of very sort of
big ego type people that I began relying
on the principles of dark Dale Carnegie
without even thinking about it that
instead of arguing and fighting and you
know trying to impose things it works a
lot better if you sort of slide around
the edges if you try to treat people in
a positive way if you try to let other
people think it's their idea of you know
that human life works a little bit
better that way so in that sense I think
this the principles are still pretty
pretty potent points
I think yes
I've heard of a place called Carnegie er
is in New York right and my impressions
with that maybe it was worth CIF to go
right right so my question is was it
after death and oh yeah we ready named
after Delk it's useful well that's a
good question too actually
Carnegie Hall is named after the steel
magnate industrialist Andrew Carnegie
but there is an interesting story that
connects him to Dale Carnegie Carnegie
originally spelled his name let's see CA
are na y GE why Carnegie and that was
the way he spelled his name until he was
in his 20s and he went to New York City
and he got an office in Carnegie Hall
and being the shrewd boy that he was he
decided that he should change the name
of his the spelling of his last name
because he said when his explanation was
that well everybody pronounced it that
way anyway so I think there was a little
bit more to it they don't think I found
fascinating about that is when he change
his spelling of his name
he removed the NA Y from the middle of
his name which I think fit very nicely
with his emphasis on positive thinking
so they're pretty sure
it's probably uh tur baloney but I
always like to say yes
Carnegie's advice was uniquely American
and I wonder if his book had worldwide
acceptance and when what cultures was
it's very much accepted in that's a good
question too it's my impression from
doing some reading I guess about sort of
the aftermath of Carnegie after his
death that the internationalization of
the Carnegie course and the Carnegie
principle sort of followed the trail of
westernization and western expansion of
the American economy after World War two
and I think it's particularly I think
there particularly Western ideas that
have to do with sort of bureaucratic
capitalism and the way things work and
as I think that begins to infiltrate
markets around the world that's that's
where the action is
I believe the Carnegie's someone at the
Carnegie company told me that
increasingly well first their big effort
was in Europe but increasingly in recent
years it's been in Asia and I think the
logic of that becomes a little bit
clearer as markets begin to permeate
Asian economies as well so I think
that's the general trajectory of that
could I ask the last question absolutely
you you sort of mentioned in passing a
very religious upbringing God's parents
D H Lawrence writing about Benjamin
Franklin and and other parts of American
literature very critically that American
literature is a part of the sort of
civic religion not a real religion and
and this is the tragic elements and in
life how would you describe Carnegie
relative it was he still a religious man
later in life he clearly was when he was
younger and influenced by his mother in
particular but that's a good question we
popped into my mind as the other D H
Lawrence tale is never trust the teller
trust the tale and I think the tale of
Carnegie
is this Carnegie overthrew religion in
his life as a young man he became sort
of agnostic and revolted against his
mother's Stern Protestantism but
interestingly in his late life I would
say about mid 40s the last decade years
of his life he returned to religion but
in a very peculiar sort of way he did
not return in terms of theology or
denomination but he returned to religion
almost as a kind of meditation and in
the last book how to stop worrying and
start living he talks a lot about the
usefulness of religion but it's very
much in a kind of therapeutic setting he
says you know I'm travelling around the
country I often everyday just take ten
minutes and I find a church any church
will do any kind of Church and I go in
and I just sit quietly and I think about
little Dale Carnegie and the big cosmos
and it sort of makes everything come
into perspective so it's a kind of the
tale of Carnegie is a little complicated
and then I think there is a kind of
renewed religiosity on the one hand but
on the other hand it's very much in that
vein of sort of therapeutic self
fulfillment rather than a kind of more
traditional Protestantism so I think
that's more or less where he ended up he
was very close friends I should add if I
can clinch the case with norman vincent
peale and he once described it he and
how did he put it he and Peele were
working the same street they were just
working different sides in the street
thank you very nice
thank you very much professor Watson
please everyone the book is for sale
from Barnes & Noble out in the in the
hall and professor Watson be happy to
join Cobb thank you very much